the Oscars were announced this week
excited about that yeah one of the that
one of the Best Picture nominees is
called parasite yeah have you I know I
thought was amazing movie parasites
great have you seen it Andy
uh oh oh yeah it's a great movie I mean
you know the story it's so good and the
cinematography it totally deserved the
nomination for sure so you really
enjoyed it huh oh yeah look obviously I
have not seen parasite I mean I don't
know why I didn't just admit it
oh well I I mean I guess I'll just be
vague and make general comments until
Conan changes the subject so Andy what
was your favorite part of parasite well
I liked how the plot kept unfolding in
unexpected ways
damnit he's getting in deeper this is a
disaster
why do I lie about everything yeah I
Andy bong joon-ho is a master at keeping
you on the edge of your seat the movie
really highlighted the class and wealth
differences in South Korea but do you
think key Tikes behavior was justified
at the end key take B yaki tyke you know
the father character
oh yeah the father character sure I am
so screwed I don't know what the father
did but wait you know what if I can step
out a time like this maybe I can run to
my office watch parasite come back and
talk about it I'll be right back hello
Andy come on Eddie what's wrong was ki
tykes behavior justified well that's
hard to say Conan I didn't watch
parasite when I left I turned on the TV
and chopped was on the Food Network I
watched a chopped marathon instead you
know I think in the context of the movie
the father's behavior was justified
I agree old pal I know Andy didn't see
the movie but he's such a pompous
know-it-all he'd never admit it I just
loved watching him squirm this way wait
so you knew I hadn't seen it but you
kept asking me about it you're a dick oh
I'm a dick well you're a liar hey and
talk about a parasite right
oh that is it you want to go Conan how
you want to go oh yeah sure I want to go
I go bring it on right now I don't care
oh wait now I'm gonna knock your head
off you know what I didn't see parasite
either oh I just I just wanted a reason
for Andy to blow his cool oh man you
really got we got a great show cleared
struggie procedures different doesn't
Larry David's here we'll be right
[Applause]